5 25 on your monday morning got a heads  up for one of henderson's busy surface  treats you know freeway projects grab  all the headlines like the big squeeze  on the 95 515 east of the spaghetti bowl  but we all know there are cones lurking  in all corners of the valley well the  city of henderson says that today  tomorrow and wednesday a repaving  project is going to have stephanie  street down to one lane in each  direction from 6 a.m to 4 p.m between  the 2 15 and just south of the union  pacific railroad tracks near american  pacific work like this usually happens  during overnight hours but henderson  says temperature requirements for las  vegas pavings asphalt are making it a  daytime project now during the work  hours getting to or from the 215 might  be easier on valley verde to the west or  gibson to the east buckle up drive  carefully and please put down that phone  comes driving you crazy email me traffic  8 8newsnow.com